but first the number of people who've
contracted the corona virus continues to
grow more than 1600 Americans now are
infected at least 40 have died in other
countries the numbers we know are far
higher a thousand have now perished in
Italy but the numbers here we know are
gonna continue to climb as more people
do get tested it's hard to meet an
American whose life hasn't already been
affected in such a short period of time
by this virus the response from the
government businesses and wall street
it's rocked our world let's face it
enough sugarcoating that schools in
America are closing my kids have been
out of school already for a week they're
gonna be out of school for the
foreseeable future
K through 12 in Ohio and Maryland
first states to shut it down colleges
like Georgetown Dartmouth Notre Dame
UCLA are all extending spring breaks or
simply canceling class for the rest of
the semester 750,000 Amazon employees
are told they can work from home if they
can
Congress in the White House are also
considering in some cases telework and
the Biden and Sanders campaigns we learn
this today have closed some offices and
told staff they can work from home the
outbreak has also ruined Americans plan
for vacation and other fun with family
and friends for the first time in 250
years including during World War two
World War one New York's beloved st.
Patty's Day Parade postponed this
morning I went to the Giant to get
dinner stuff for the kids and not only
were there no grocery carts there wasn't
even any ketchup believe it or not
that's what I needed and people who are
filling their carts with cases of water
dog food and frozen pizza wait a second
is there a shortage or on pepperoni and
dough I mean is there a run on flour and
water I just I have to miss that well at
least you're gonna have sports to watch
while you're cooped up with all the kids
wrong
remainder of the NBA and now NHL seasons
have been suspended then Major League
Baseball has delayed opening day and
canceled spring training and those
stories continue to wrack up there
some bizarre stories you may have missed
in Aspen Colorado the ski town of the
celebs they have ten coronavirus cases
the most concentrated cluster and the
entire very large state of Colorado and
some Aussie tourists there who came into
contact with this infected person are
there and they're just refusing to be
tested can't force them to be tested by
the way I guess it's time to pull their
lift tickets maybe families are feeling
pressure to cancel baptisms dance
recitals a friend of mine has had to
postpone their son's wedding I was going
to it next week in New Orleans that's
postponed it's gonna continue though the
drag on the economy the markets it's a
nightmare we all see it the stock market
dropped the most since a crash of 87 the
markets today plummeted the Dow plunging
almost 10 percent and suffering its
worst loss since 1987
in total the markets have lost almost
three trillion dollars on the day
there's no question it was a bloodbath
in the market not just today but in the
last couple of weeks and while there
have been some layoffs already jobless
claims have actually dropped in the
first week of March but of course that
will likely change so are the demands
for more federal money though and
government controls don't forget this is
election season we're still in the
middle of a presidential election the
Democrat debate I guess on Sunday is
still going on between Sanders and Biden
and the Democrat machine just spent a
lot of effort trying to kill off Sanders
and the whole campaign of Bernie Sanders
because they said they didn't think a
self-described socialist was electable
moderates like Joe Biden you know said
he was too extreme for the American
people but it turns out the party
establishment as we see this coronavirus
aid package and all the details of its
surface they're more comfortable with
socialism than they're letting on just
look at what they're trying to cram down
our throats under the guise of
responding to the viral outbreak
Pelosi's coronavirus bill is full of
socialist goodies like ending work
requirements for food stamps for
everyone mandating employers provide
paid leave benefits even beyond national
I seized taxpayers footing the bill for
coronavirus tests for the uninsured and
in some deliberations for the rest of
the world it's so bad that Republicans
are refusing to vote for it tonight
here's one glaring problem under Pelosi
bill the Social Security Administration
would be set up to administer the paid
sick leave program now this will take
more than six months so it won't work in
time
it also will hamper the administration
from putting out Social Security for
those who need it right now that are in
harm's way this will hurt the very
population that we're supposed to be
helping well the Democrats delayed the
vote on the aid package as they continue
to negotiate with the White House Pelosi
this morning sounded very optimistic
about working with Steve nooshin
Treasury secretary saying there he had
reasonable points to be made but that
kind of seemed to all come to a halt at
some point during the day but much of
what the Democrats are pushing doesn't
deal with the crisis at hand and only
seems to in some cases set a floor for
future government control and spending
and in the end this will be dealt with
at some point this will be a memory
thank goodness we hope it's sooner
rather than later but in the end the
average person is always asked to cough
up more money and in return they get
less freedom
it's socialism by crisis and there's no
hiding it nice try